anybody hear a skittles fan yeah I love  him can I say something  I always thought Skittles were whatevers  man [ __ ] you dude  get him get him say the word  bite-sized candy M M's and then Reese's  no it's a different category  is chocolate little [ __ ] little color  beads chocolate and fruit are different  different M M's has the candy coated  chocolate Market by far M M's Tic Tacs  all is in categories so you can eat  those all together in your mouth candy  necklaces where do you put that in do  you wear that with M M's too candy  necklaces  Smarties is here Skittles down here  today Smarties  okay what about Sweet Tarts what about  Pez yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah where do  you put Pez dude oh dude like